on vous dit berne est la forme ont
travaillé le moteur de mon existence mon
opium ma cocaïne mon prozac
c'était plaît oui ah ben oui j'aime
jouer alors on va parler de vous on va
voir un peu votre vie qui est assez
extraordinaire
[Applaudissements]
hu ils ont du talent sa télévision
c'est clair on dit au début alors vous
êtes né à nîmes
vos parents étaient protestants et ils
désespéraient d'avoir un enfant malgré
dix ans de vie commune et un jour ils
vont rendre visite à des cousins dans le
sud ouest
il s'arrête à lourdes et miracle il
avait fait un voyage effectivement dans
les pyrénées et puis en rentrant elle
s'est trouvée enceinte et comme elle
voulait avoir un fils j'ai porté des
pantalons sommerhof jusqu'à l'été en
quoi et on m'appelait bernard et votre
père voulait absolument qu'on vous fasse
pas couper les cheveux parce qu'il
disait alors effectivement les amis
catholiques de vos parents en attendant
cette histoire de miracle à lourdes en
redemander et votre mère précise et de
twitter ou catholiques nous avions
demandé un garçon qu'on les emmerder
quant aux protestants et j'y croyais pas
jusqu'en sixième vous vivez à saint
geniès de malgoirès et puis ensuite au
lycée de nîmes
votre père était par masia comme tous
les pères de grands réalisateurs de
nouvelles vagues d'ailleurs chabrol ma
science y voilà mais beaucoup de la
masia votre père était fou des gens
connus et reconnus des reculs il disait
ça ça me faisait tellement ça me
comprenais pas il est il est très
admiratif insula il est connu et précis
et reconnus pour vous c'était le top 7
comment faire pour plaire à son passé
ferrand
je voulais que nous dirons plus il
fallait être reconnu il pas seulement
connue comment est reconnue pour un
meurtre en même temps c'est vrai donc
vous vous étiez folle de paris match à
la rubrique l est
vous découpez les photos d audrey
hepburn de silvana mangano riz amer
marlon brando et jean babilée ouais je
suis un peu délurée déjà taillé pas
beaucoup de latitude dans la propriété
de vos parents dans les cévennes vous
aviez une pièce que vous aviez repeinte
en bleu indigo qui était un club privé
qui s'appelait le west end club de
mandater le bout du monde les cévennes à
l'époque les routes en lacets pour y
arriver elle s'offrait anita et bettina
et donc j'ai pu épouser action dit les
garçons dans ce club que vous aviez créé
quoi oui et je n'ai pas non
j'en avais pas le de même pas une sacrée
allumeuse quand même parce que vos
parents alors ça c'est incroyable mais
si mais si tel éditeur toute façon ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que les parents
seraient les parents de bernadette
laffont était en proie à une sexualité
intense
c'est vrai oui je crois qu'ils
s'envoyaient bien en l'air ensemble
c'était moins crapuleuse
oui ce qu'on appelle dans le milieu à
sieste crapuleuse c'est à dire qu'après
déjeuner connexion fiable et votre père
le père était un homme charmant
d'ailleurs être écrite et votre mère
comme d'une maîtresse il lui éviter les
tâches domestiques
il était très dévoué à sa femme et leur
communauté par mattia il avait des
aphrodisiaques et un jour bernadette
lafont a retrouvé dans un tiroir de la
cantharide à l'été c'est bien dommage
c'est bien dommage dans leur apparence
avez dit étrange était à la fois sévère
et libéraux c'est à dire très à cheval
sur les horaires et en même temps à vous
laisser vous habiller comme vous vouliez
oui c'est marrant ça donc j'aime
m'habiller vraiment comme une [ __ ]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est vrai que vouliez vous
avez vous pouviez vous avez comme une
[ __ ] mais évidemment que meurtrier alors
voilà c'est tout vous vous retrouviez
comme ça anime assise seule dans un café
on revient juste au corps si vous êtes
on peut le dire l'inventrice du body
d'une certaine façon c'était des trucs
de shalla pectoraux je faisais de la
danse bah oui encore dit jean le jin fei
s'allonger pour les enfiler oui puis on
allait se tremper dans la méditerranée
puis on les laisser sécher elle avec
tout le sel du mexique n'ont jamais eu
lieu
[Applaudissements]
mais bernadette lafont allumer les
maigres les mecs vous offrez un sens à
nos que vous ne pouviez pas quand même
enfin c'était comme ça et alors il était
là en train de vous raconter des
histoires en train de vous charmer vous
dit en fait il me regardait avec un
regard de maquignons qui sont pas là
mais pourquoi je faisais ça pour arriver
à la question qu'est ce que tu fais où
elle habite
la réponse était je fais du cinéma et
l'italie en italie silvana mangano pas
d'accord et oui j'ai été député à l'âge
de 16 ans
là
il y va
voilà l'âge de 16 ans par le dénommé
josé qui était coiffeur et qui buvaient
des nations
qu'y avait il y avait une lambretta
parce que pour emballer les gonzesses à
nîmes vient d'avoir la langue ouattara
et alors vous avez vécu il faut le dire
on peut le dire cette première
expérience alors votre copine and i ll
pousser des cris formidable ça lui
plaisait beaucoup vous en fait vécu
c'est un peu comme l'extraction d'une
dent de sagesse non sens sinon mes
services
non c'est vrai oui j'avoue que c'est pas
de meilleur souvenir nantais que des
puces là non comment ça s'est passé le
vôtre
[Applaudissements]
je vais je obligé je pose des questions
tellement insensé aux enjeux sont
obligés de répondre quand on me les pose
gtdi jockey whisky à gogo agents l'est
pas et alors il y avait un disque était
going home des rolling stones duré onze
minutes 35 et j'ai profité de ces onze
minutes parce que vous étiez d'izieu
qu'est-ce que 4 heures du matin des fois
cinq heures j'ai profité de ces onze
minutes pour m'enfuir dans la pinède de
juan les pins qui est en face au whisky
à gogo et donc ça a duré voyez quoi des
circulations précoce la première mais un
jour je continue l'histoire de perdre à
être la fin mais un jour à nîmes à
l'endroit même où vos parents s'étaient
rencontrés vous rencontrez le cinéma en
la personne de gérard blain satu quo
n'est pas durable c'était le james dean
français alors ils étaient là parce
qu'ils étaient venus répéter une pièce
pour les arènes de nîmes
jules césar et avec arme entier et
stéphane audran il y avait gérard
lebovici comprends pas trop pourquoi
mais enfin qui faisait de la figuration
il voulait être acteur gérard leibovitz
avant et vous les tracteurs sinon et
finalement l'été situationniste c'est
bizarre comme quoi à notre âge est un
autre jeu ouais et alors donc gérard
blain il faut dire les choses il avait
une voiture noire avec l'intérieur rouge
évident ça vous accomplir avoir la
chance est complètement séduit alors
voilà bombe à limonade baiser le mariage
se profile
et là évidemment d'eni vont commencer à
chuchoter elle se marie avec une vedette
de paris évidemment il ya des jalousies
il ya des lettres du corbeau qui arrive
chez vous parce c'est vrai nom c'est
vraiment radier des lettres qui arrive
chez vos parents bien sûr bien sûr en
disant toute façon les enceintes c'est
pour ça qu'elle se marie n'hésitez pas
du tout enceinte
un jour gérard blain vient demander
votre main à vos parents et la première
fois choisi de le dire parce que l'info
fait l'amour avec lui vous lui fait
croire que vous êtes viage et je me suis
dit si je lui dis que non il va être
tellement vax et ouais je savais déjà
que les hommes étaient extrêmement
chatouilleux sur cette histoire de bits
donc c'est vrai mais c'est vrai donc
voila vous l'épouser mais lui est en
fête et obsédé bernadette bernadette
pluie est obsédé par le fait que vous
ayez très envie de faire du cinéma il
avait été marié avec et stella blain
savait pas duré longtemps et vous disais
toi au moins tu es pas comme tout cecon
tu veux pas devenir actrice alors que
c'était le rêve de votre vie et vous
comprenez bien gérable voilà donc que
vous faites quelques photos en maillot
de bain pour mettre du beurre dans les
épinards parce qu'il n'est pas non plus
des cachets mirobolants gérard blain et
puis vous rencontrez il vous présente
l'équipe des cahiers du cinéma
c'était le début de votre de votre
carrière dahmane ascension fulgurante
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai et d'ailleurs
vous dire s'il m'avait présenté verneuil
autant-lara j'aurais fait une autre
carrière quoi mais il vous a présenté
les gens des cahiers du cinéma
alors bon atout cité mais en pharmacie
télé les plus grands enfin les premiers
dijon n'a pas présenté en faire on les a
connus et on a tourné les films voilà
ensemble alors vous avez tourné en 57
les mistons de françois truffaut avoir
en 59 sortie du beau serge avec gérard
blain film de chabrol 60 les bonnes
femmes je vois qu'ils voient la preuve
on les fait tous les grands films la
nouvelle vague
on vous appelait à l'époque la vamp
villageoise ça c'était quand le beau
serge est sorti ils ont dit ça et ils
ont dit aussi lampes comique
ah oui c'est mieux vaut villageoise est
alors hervé guibert des années plus tard
vous appelez la bardot [ __ ] ça c'est
beau ce qu'il a écrit un très beau
papier sur l'amour est aveugle mais
voilà vous étiez la petite fiancée du
cinéma français comme on dit quoi
c'était vous et alors vous avez une
explication de la nouvelle vague qui est
absolument extraordinaire vite qu'on
fait la nouvelle vague c'est parce qu'on
avait inventé une nouvelle pellicule qui
s'appelait l'atrix et qu'en fait on
pouvait filmer dehors sans l'agrégation
lumière c'est vrai c'est pas une
révolution technique sinon avant c'était
pas possible
cinq ou dix ans avant bien sûr c'est
toujours ma marrant quand on explique
quelque chose d'artistique en fait par
une innovation technique c'est comme
aujourd'hui on invente des caméras tout
petit qui filme la nuit donc on peut
faire des émissions différentes de
celles d'avant voila voila l époque vous
avez failli tourner à bout de souffle
oui parce que ils voulaient jean seberg
pour faire le rôle qu'elle a fait
d'ailleurs et il imaginer la paire quoi
les garçons la fille est donc avec jean
seberg cd belmondo oui et puis comme
jean seberg était sous contrat avec
preminger à olemps ii pour des années il
y avait un moment où c'était compliqué
et ça a failli ne pas se faire et à ce
moment là moi j'ai tourné à double tour
avec chabrol à aix-en-provence et il est
descendu il m'a dit si je peux pas avoir
jean donc je change le couple et est ce
que vous pourriez faire avec aznavour
souhaité drôle à blizzard alors gérard
blain vous reproche de plus en plus
votre liaison avec le 7ème art il est
jaloux en fait il est jaloux du fait que
vous fassiez l'actrice n'est pas une
femme donc il m'a renvoyé après le beau
serge
c'est moi il vous obliger à dire que
vous aviez dix sept ans qu'on vous en
aviez 19
vous avez vous avez sorti croyez le bien
avec petit je pense parce que c'était la
blague quand ils ont été tellement je
crois qu'il était tombé aussi amoureux
de moi parce que j'avais 16 ans et demi
oui donc il n'avait pas envie que j'ai
plus sur ce vous tomber enceinte vous
fait avorter parce que vous dites
d'ailleurs pas question de garder
l'enfant de nos amours défuntes
et puis voilà puis ça se termine comme
ça avec gérard blain et la maison ça se
termine pas comme ça parce que tu as mis
toute notre vie mabon est toujours en
service
je savais pas de plaisir oui on
s'entendait beaucoup mieux quand on
était ensemble ce que je ne pouvais pas
être la femme qui voulait avoir c'est à
dire une femme qui reste à la maison
a lille a trouvé après une femme qu'une
wii marie-hélène oui c'est le petit marc
gérard il est mort lambiner duris et oui
absolument
voilà vous rencontrez du jour km les
skis alors ça c'est terrible
un slave comme son nom l'indiqué non pas
du tout en droit c'est pas cela
rien à voir mahdia madjar donc c'était
un sculpteur artiste maudit qui vous
fait trois enfants que vous pondent est
comme ça les grands pour seulement comme
une poule pond disait exactement malheur
une lettre à la poste je ne suis pas je
les ai pas vues passer ses trois mois
d'août mois non attendez là là là
l'heure est grave
il vous faisait peur un peu ce
dur canon et vous ai peur un peu détient
peu envoûté par lui mais quelque chose
de compliqué je vous avais décidé être
honnête ça ne fait triste journée avec
un couteau
c'est vrai que c'est facile et gens nous
connaissent et nous dossier et donc
voilà alors vous avez marre jour
d'habiter dans cette baraque à 50 bande
de paris de ne pas fait pour ça tous vos
potes et vos copines vous dit qu'est ce
que tu fais là bas donc vous finissez
par revenir
et là votre carrière redémarre et où
fait ce film merveilleux qui est la
fiancée du pirate et ensuite vous faites
la maman et la [ __ ]
et là vous évidemment tout le monde ait
survécu parce qu'on attend vous fassiez
la plus tard et vous faites la maman
antistar anti star voilà et puis après
on fait de nombreux films qu'on va tous
cités dont l'effrontée qui vous a
rapporté un césar ont l'habitude air et
un jour et là j'en arrive à vous
mesdemoiselles un jour vous découvrez le
théâtre vaut aussi ces requins joal
monte
vous montez sur une sur une scène de
théâtre et vous avez une espèce de
sensations comme ça complètement inédite
pour vous une exaltation extraordinaire
et vous dites c'est comme au cinéma
quand j'ai commencé qu'on disait moteur
non j'ai pas dit ça
[Applaudissements]
milhas survivre tout va mieux
doux comme un agneau lui alors je suis
doux comme un agneau les convient de le
chanter fernandel allez-y vous avez dit
quoi vous avez je me souviens très bien
je me suis dit j'ai fait un aveu comme
ça une sorte d'élan mystique un peu
disons j'étais derrière gelé juste passé
pour jouer cette comtesse sanglante dont
il était le premier rôle et j'ai dit je
veux bien ne plus jamais faire du cinéma
si je peux toujours père du théâtre
voilà et d'ailleurs est d'ailleurs 5
janvier 2002 vous allez jouer donc les
eaux de patrick lunan au petit théâtre
de paris alors que moi est une tête vous
allez faire le pitch alors la situation
au début de la pièce
c'est un jeune homme qui est dans une
sorte de studio d'enregistrement qui
tourne en rond on sent qu'il a tant qu
il est angoissé et l'interphone sonne
dit c'est toi pierre et la réponse est
non ce n'est pas pierre ces mamans c'est
moi maman et donc j'arrive là c'est mon
fils je n'avais pas vu depuis 10 ans lui
est ravagée parce que il est dans un
grand grand grand chagrin d'amour
et moi je viens lui dire que je sais
qu'il est [ __ ] et ces deux personnes qui
se ceux qui s'accrochent très très très
très fort là dessus mais en même temps
ça permet d'ouvrir plein de tiroirs is
par l'espagne c'était un grand film sur
en fait il est homosexuel mais pour être
autre chose c'est une mère un fils et ça
va loin quoi et c'est très beau ça
s'appelle les os et écrit par patrick
lui non c'est au petit théâtre de paris
ya aussi une jeune fille qui est donc la
fiancée du fils qui donne un espoir à la
mer mais en fait ça va être un mariage
blanc à ce que les sri lankaise et qu'il
faut qu'elles aient des papiers c'est
comme ça pour qu'elle voit la cbc les
l'histoire de ce film de cette pièce
parce que oui
on peut importer des accessoires s'il
vous plaît matin une interview croyances
et je voulais
il apporte quelques accessoires pour
cette interview croyants
et
c'est bien
c'est parfait
et je sais faire
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez en dieu dans la
pièce je dis mais pourquoi j'avais mon
dieu je suis folle je ne crois en rien
mais si je crois en la vie je crois en
la vie voilà je vous croyez en vous mais
chez avec si vous priiez aux anges
gardiens oui aux anges tout court oui
gardien pas gardien y en a des mésanges
aussi oui oui aussi oui il ya des des
diablotins way lescout cru au père noël
plis muriel non non non je fais
attention mais on s'est quand même non
non parce que j'étais petit j'ai cru
après je n'y ai plus crue et j ai
recrues ouais un joli ça peut peut-être
me revenir entre les marchés en vous y
croyez peut-être d'autres d'ailleurs à
la fin des matches ça fait du bien
l'ensemble vocal ou fantôme oui oui oui
heureusement gré est ce que vous voyez à
la réincarnation
moi je crois qu'on a plusieurs vies déjà
dans sa vie on sera incapable jusqu'à
lyon sera un candidat dit tout à fait
prêt à superman c'est qui déjà suis là
bas c'est celui qui veulent la ou
superman c'est là où il y avait dix
qu'olson qui faisait le chanteur
-
ramzy l'avez inventé moyens man c'est le
mec qui volait mes à ça est ce que vous
croyez à la fidélité
maintenant oui à cause de quoi vous avez
été sûrement d'abord est-ce que c'est
pas votre émission hockey s est ce que
vous croyez au sexe sans amour à l'amour
sans sexe ouais ça tourne sur muriel le
sang a mûri je crois moi vrai hélas mon
sens aix aussi c'est bien là ça marche à
tous les coups fumants
léa je vous demande pas vous êtes la
nièce de michel drucker jeu est-ce que
jusque là ou là là et vous oubliez cette
question est ce que vous croyez qu'on
peut faire l'amour cinq fois de suite
oui
muriel je trouverais veut cela j'aime
pas très beaucoup de chiffres impairs
donc je serais plutôt pour ses 106 jeu
très bien
[Musique]